بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اخي صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان
حفظه الله
الاخوه القاده اصحاب الجلاله والسمو
والفخامه
معالي الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
الحضور الكريم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
اتوجه بالتحيه والتقدير لاخي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز حفظه
الله ولكم اخي صاحب السمو الملكي ولي
العهد على استضافه هذه القمه العربيه
التي نثق بانها ستنجح في مواجهه التحديات
الاقليميه والعالميه
التي تواجه امتنا
وتحويلها لفرص تعزز الامن والاستقرار
والسلام في منطقتنا وتحقق طموحات وامال
شعوب امتنا العربيه وفي هذه المناسبه
فاننا نشيد بما حققته المملكه من انجازات
تحت قيادتكم على جميع المستويات على طريق
الرفعه
والنمائي والازدهار كما اتوجه بالشكر
عرفان لاخي فخامه الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون
رئيس الجمهوريه الجزائريه الشعبيه
الديمقراطيه على رئاسته الناجحه للقمه
السابقه
ووجهه بهذه المناسبه تحيه كبار وتقدير
لاشقائنا قاده الدول العربيه
والشعوبها على مواقبهم الثابته تجاه شعبنا
وقضيتنا العادله كما
ونرحب بزياده الرئيس بشار الاسد رئيس
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه اخا عزيزا بين
اهله واخوانه الاخ الرئيس
في قرار اممي تاريخيا غير مسبوق احييت
الامم المتحده في مقرها بنيويورك منذ ايام
الذكرى 75 للنكبه نكبه الشعب الفلسطيني
التي لا زالت تتوالى احداثها واثارها
الماساويه منذ العام
1948 حتى يومنا هذا والتي ارتكبت العصابات
الصهيونيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
خلالها اكثر من 51 مجزره موثقه لدينا
ودمرت اكثر من 530 قريه فلسطينيه
موثقه لدينا
ان هذا القرار الاممي التاريخي الهام يشكل
بحضا للروايه الصهيونيه الاسرائيليه التي
تنكرت للنكبه ولفت الروايات المزيفه حول
علاقات الشعب الفلسطيني بارض وطنه
والجرائم التي ارتكبت بحقهم
اننا ايها السيدات والساده نؤكد رفض دار
استمرار السباحه سلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لارضنا ومقدساتنا ونطالب
المجتمع الدولي بمحاسبه اسرائيل على
جرائمها بحق شعبنا وانتهاكاتها للقانون
الدولي
وتوفير الحمايه الدوليه له ونحن من جانبنا
سنواصل مسيرتنا النضاليه لمواجهه القهر
والعدوان الاسرائيلي كما سنواصل
جهودنا الدولماسيه والقانونيه في المحافل
والمحاكم كافه لاستعاده حقوق شعبنا وفي
المقدمه منها المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
ومحكمه العدل الدوليه اضافه الى استمرار
السعي
للحصول على العضويه الكامله في الامم
المتحده وهنا
يعمل منكم جميعا الوقوف الى جانبنا لدعم
تنفيذ قرار الجمعيه العامه الاخير وتقديم
المرافعه
المكتوبه من قبل جوالكم امام محكمه العدل
الدوليه على امل ان تصدر هذه المحكمه
رايها الاستشاري وفتواها حول قانونيه وشكل
واهليه النظام الذي اقامته اسرائيل دوله
الاحتلال والاببارتاين على ارض فلسطين وفي
هذا الصدر نؤكد استعدادنا للعمل مع هذه
القمه العربيه
بقياده المملكه العربيه السعوديه من اجل
انجاح الجهود العربيه والاغلبيه والدوليه
في اطار من الشراكه والتعارون وايجاد حلول
لازمات المنطقه وصولا لتحقيق الامن
والسلام والازدهار لشعوبنا وفي الختام
نتقدم بالشكر والتقدير لاشقائنا قاده
وشعوب امتنا العربيه على مواقفهم السياسيه
ثابته لدعم الشعب الفلسطيني
وعلى السعوديه كافه وكلنا ثقه باستمرار
تقديم هذا الدعم السياسي والمادي لتعزيز
صمود وبقاء الشعب الفلسطيني على ارضه
ومواصله بلا مؤسسات دولته
المستقله واخيرا وليس اخرا نقول لشعبنا
الفلسطيني البطل اننا نفتخر بكم
في كل واحد منكم في الوطن وفي الشتات
ونعتذر ونعتز بمسيرتنا النضاليه وسوف
نواصل العمل من اجل وحده شعبنا وارضنا
وتحقيق المصالحه الوطنيه على اساس
الالتزام بمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
والشرعيه الدوريه والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه وال وتقارير الاخباريه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات